not had your professional life and you'd
settle down earlier 100 yeah yeah 100 I
was just saying it to my sister the
other day um I wish I got married at
around 18 19 20. by now my child would
have been
teenager you know it it just would have
been a lot easier I'm I've got a
you know a child that's just out of the
toddler phase and I'm knackered because
I find that nowadays what they're saying
the women is like yeah work get your
career
when you can have a child and then when
I come along and say well we want to
serve a child that late yeah I mean like
why would you want to do that why not
encourage the youth to settle down
earlier but now it just seems like
for me it's like all backwards now it's
a lifestyle that I wouldn't have felt
like I was letting go of because I just
grew up and then I got married of which
I wanted to and that is where life began
whereas before it's like I'm living this
one lifestyle and it's about to like
switch to a completely different one so
sometimes like you're living a bit
double like not double minded but like
your mind is where it was and sometimes
you're trying to merge the two or
sometimes like you're kind of grieving
what it used to be it's you can't really
be present it's just yeah it's just a
lot of
feelings and memories because I mean
I've I've never heard of a Muslim woman
working so many years
you know I mean well done to you because
you studied and you worked in there yeah
yeah but that's unusual for me and the
people that the Muslims that I know
today is really unusual yeah so um
I know a couple yeah
um I've always been headstrong like I'm
the eldest and there's six of us
so I've always wanted to kind of set an
example for my siblings and not only you
know integrate into the Western world
but also
I had this independent woman mindset I
want to make my own money yeah I want to
do my own thing and I wasn't paying
attention to reality and reality for me
and I'm not you know whoever has you
know their opinions that's up to them
but for me reality is a family consists
of a man and a woman and the man is the
head of the family what he's he gets the
last word and me I'm there to nurture
I'm there to mother I'm there to you
know just make everyone feel better and
just do what needs to be done just
understand it I need to click with him
you know we both need I need to know
that and trust that he can take care of
the hard stuff
so would you think that it would have
been easier for you and your husband
if you met him when he was like say 17
before you had all the careers no I
would have gotten married to an older
man with the mindset that I've got now
I've gotten married to an older man
who's already established and who is
looking for a younger wife and a lot of
men that's what they want because the
younger you are your fertility like you
could have more kids you know
um
and you're more fertile sorry you're not
having more kids
um so I would have looked for an old man
that would take care of would you marry
a guy that's 55 now
I don't know I don't know if there's 50
some I mean I'm 35 so that's only 20
years right but
50 year olds nowadays they just I don't
know like we've got two complete
completely different mindsets and I just
don't know any older than that yeah yeah
yeah no no no no no no no no it's just
it's interesting because you said you
would have married older but now because
I'm thinking at 35 like a 45 year old
guy can go down to like 25 but a 55 year
old guy like 35 is Young to him so I'm
saying like you know that's the
equivalent wow I'm uh so I'm in a
different place in my life now but had I
have been 18 or 19 a 30 something year
old wouldn't have been as a scary right
right okay um yeah can I ask sorry
something you said before I'm just
intrigued about it why do you think the
man should always have the last word
what did you mean if he's if he's a
masculine man who has been bought up
right
and he knows
what a woman's right is so in Islam they
teach you about what a woman's right is
how you know what Goddess how God
expects you to treat that woman if he
understands that
then I trust that whatever decision he's
making is for my best interest and for
our family's best interest not to say
that I don't know what's good for us but
we're emotional creatures sometimes we
think illogically and they don't have
you ever dated a guy that you could
control
not asking me yeah
that's a big question uh-huh
um
[Laughter]
yeah
um and how did that end
it ended did you like it no I'm saying
no who broke up I didn't I like to be
put in my place I love that yeah
I love it that's her point though okay
you wouldn't even like a guy that wants
you to have the last word no no yeah I
want someone that can challenge me and
put me in my place but also appreciate
when I have a good point to convey no
you can sit down and have a conversation
we will talk about it and you know he
will take my opinion into consideration
but at the end of the day
he is making that decision for our
family and I know that and I understand
that very well all right I'm with you
yeah cool
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats and
then I think we're going to close out
the show Auntie did you you just seemed
like you wanted to say something no I
was gonna do that oh okay okay I'm gonna
Read Super chats really quick I'm gonna
let you guys do final thoughts so you
can plug any social media or you know
anything you want to say
that is not disrespectful
after last time
um also update Esther is banned from the
show anyone was wondering
don't worry about it
will you check out I mean you check a
channel you'll find out yeah okay
um Despicable D um question for the lady
next to Auntie in Investment Banking how
is money created and destroyed
um Nicholas nasty women used to earn
safety fund over time in the form of
gold silver and jewelry the gifts used
to have more meaning behind them wearing
gold and silver with money still does
some in some places in the world Andrew
luster
came into the stream late so I didn't
catch names but this lady in the black
leather jacket is based AF bless you for
being a beacon of light on the podcast
um narcy boy is indiscriminate verbal
road rage a deal breaker no wait wait
answer me is indiscriminate verbal road
rage a deal breaker
I know Andy's answer to that yeah it is
it should be a deal breaker for men yeah
for both of us both sixes except Auntie
my ex got pissed at me once she was like
WTF those are kids I'm despicable D I
wouldn't get married again but the wife
is I'd want would be respectful brings
peace and intimacy and handles hurt end
in the day today it's not rocket science
so Auntie when will Pearl see the Dance
Floor
she missed the class today because she
she had a match she had a I had a class
today at that school she said that you
were doing volleyball oh I did have a
game yeah yeah I did um yabba dabba Al
just wanted to say you look beautiful
pearl I love the way you did your hair
I'm a newlywed and watched to learn as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible